we are here to talk about feature stores
and recommender systems
uh so a little background about me so i
currently work at tacton with a focus on
feast which is the open source feature
store that we offer
and i manage that team but prior to that
i was at google
leading some machine learning systems
within google workspace
so yeah i'm excited to talk to you today
about and nerd out about all the feature
source space
and a quick
high-level agenda of what i want to
cover today so i want to first align
this on roughly like you know what is a
recommender system what is a feature
store
both of those i think are actually
fairly ambiguous terms
and then i'm going to go over some
challenges that i typically see people
going through when they're building
recommender systems
and then specifically hone into a couple
of them so like how do you build low
latency
systems like this how do you ensure
correctness
and then finally if i have time i'm
going to try to sneak in uh how you
might integrate feast into your
workflows to to get value out of a
such a system
so yeah what is a recommender system
i think that there's a lot of turns out
a lot of different definitions out there
i'm going to give you my personal take
on this
and my personal take is really this is
any kind of system where you're trying
to match
one kind of entity to another kind of
entity so
uh the canonical examples of this would
be e-commerce would you where you're
matching users to items that they want
to purchase
or media streaming where you're matching
users to videos
but i think it goes a lot broader than
that so
you know i was reading like a very
interesting paper by astrazeneca where
they are trying to do drug discovery
which is basically you're trying to
match drugs to
diseases that are going to solve a cure
right and so those are
there's a lot of different use cases
that all match this kind of paradigm
that all suffer from the same kind of
like challenges right
um and then i think there's also two
big
kind of ways you build recommender
systems one of them is what i call batch
predictions which is where you
pre-compute all of your recommendations
that you want to serve to the users and
then you cache them and you want to like
serve them online right
maybe you're doing this every single day
so this might be like a
for like the amazon homepage you
pre-compute every single user's like
first default landing page and then you
serve them
when the user hits the website right and
that's to be contrasted with online
predictions which kind of
are where really in that same example
when the user clicks on the website
you're live computing
the recommendations on the spot based
off of the information they have
available at that time right so
um
and what i've been seeing in the
community is that most people start with
the batch predictions use case this is
like way easier to build
and uh kind of generally you know if you
can get away with it that's where i
would just stop almost
but i am seeing a very large trend
towards like where the most business
critical problems you move into that
online world right and as you can
imagine with an online recommender
system you introduce a long tail of
operational challenges
yeah here i call out that there's
in practice a lot of times you have this
candidate generation step and a
re-ranking step so candidate generation
is where uh you for example filter down
items you have like millions of items
what was that
oh sorry did not realize um yeah so uh
where you typically have you know
millions of items and you're filtering
them down to maybe like a set of 100 or
a thousand and then you have a
re-ranking model that figures out which
of those hundred or a thousand are the
most important for for the users to see
right
so apologies for that
um yep and then what is a feature store
and a feature store i think is similarly
ambiguous
to recommend our system perhaps even
more so so my take on a feature store is
really
it's a piece of infrastructure that owns
the entire life cycle
of a feature kind of from
how do you
translate from the raw data into
features all the way down to like how do
you end up using them and there's kind
of two different ways you might use them
right you might be training data
training based on that data for you know
your data scientists are interacting
with this
or you might be having a an online
production system that needs to access
features you know very very quickly
right so feature service should
own the entire lifecycle of this of that
data
and kind of with that definition in mind
there's a bunch of downstream benefits
which i'm not going to go through
because we are short on time
so let me walk you through
a typical journey of how a company uh uh
you know days of old kind of company
would actually go about doing this i
think this is actually kind of different
nowadays where
um you know sometimes you're a company
that's like i need to sneak in ammo into
my pitch deck to get funding so maybe
you start early a little bit earlier on
but you know take like the example of
the e-commerce website typically people
are building a
core business first and then they kind
of move more and more gradually into
recommender systems so you might be
building a website that's uh allows
users to buy items to sell items and
then have a purchase history that they
can see
right and then kind of the company some
sealable executive will say
well how do i kind of generate more
business how do i get
um you know users to buy more items and
that's where you might throw in a
heuristic right so maybe you'll show
like the most popular items
uh in a particular category as just a
quick initial heuristic
and then kind of the company then
realizes well that doesn't really do too
much that does you know a little bit
right but you actually want to be
suggesting based off of you know a much
more dynamic set of data you want to
train based off your data and that's
where you start moving into this
batch recommendations and that batch
predictions kind of mode that i talked
about right and that's kind of where
most users will stop
which i think is perfectly fine gets
most of the job done
but increasingly there's a lot more you
just kind of move past that and go into
this online recommender world right and
then that last step there is where you
actually need to you know often you
actually add even more layers on top of
this so
as an example with youtube um
you have to think about how do you
encourage more diversity of videos how
do you encourage email fairness and
those introduce additional
pre and post processing steps
um so there's a lot of challenges
i keep doing this guide there's a lot of
challenges with uh
recommender systems and
i'm not going to go through all of them
i just wanted to kind of call out some
broad categories here
so there's some operational challenges
here as we've discussed there's unique
challenges with respect to feature
engineering in recommender systems
and
you know since you're moving data around
a lot there's a lot of opportunity for
data quality to
just go bad and then
there's organizational components to
this like you're working with different
kinds of
users data scientists data engineers
kind of infra engineers within an
organization
and kind of you know i couldn't really
figure out the right category but this
last miscellaneous bucket also was
really really important privacy and
i think guys said cold start yes uh call
star they're all very very important
a couple ones i wanted to call out here
um one of them that's kind of ambiguous
is access to request data so
the way that this kind of manifests is
often some of the most useful features
you want to get access to
are uh need to be computed on flight so
for example i think time is a really
good example of this so like if you are
trying to
predict what a user's buying patterns
will be you will need to understand like
what time of the day is it
what day of the week might it be even
like what kind of season during the year
for you to accurately kind of predict
what they need and that l cannot be
really encapsulated accurately in a
batch predictions model right
yeah so what i do want to quickly dive
more deeply into is some of the
operational challenges
going to this and uh kind of the quick
two highlights here was that
um
one of one of the big challenges is how
do you have really fresh features so
like uh features that are kind of
computed and accurate
you know as as accurate as possible to
this point in time
um and that often results in a pretty
right heavy system
um and we're going to kind of dive into
why that's challenging and why that's
important but you can imagine that you
know like i just talked about how
requested it can be important there's a
lot of other information that's really
important such as like you're using your
user session data
your preferences over the course of a
session are going to be shifting pretty
rapidly so you also need to take that
into account
right and then the second bucket is
more focused on how do you actually
fetch feature data for of for a bunch of
entities at the same time and this is
this kind of goes into that like
re-ranking step where you need to figure
out obviously hundreds or thousands
of items how do you you know which ones
are most important so you really want to
get a lot of features in a short period
amount of time right
yeah so when i think about achieving
lower latency this is obviously a very
big simplification there's a lot of
challenges that come into here three i
wanted to call out so one of them is
balancing all the requirements that you
have so like
read versus write and like optimizing
for cost
there's another kind of aspect which is
around type conversions which i think is
really interesting and a pretty hard to
solve problem
and then finally there's also just like
the whole branch of optimizations that
go into
making a batch retrieval
api performance
and so the first one i wanted to dive
into is
uh how do you actually build uh how do
you balance these requirements right so
there's a lot of things um
in this list
two of them are kind of balancing that
the you have two different challenges
one of them is that you want to have
very fresh features you want to have
very frequent like streams that are
updating um the features that you have
access to at serving time
but you also want to get access to those
features very very quickly right and i
highlight two example strategies on the
right but i think it's more instructive
to look at a potential example here
so here on the left side you see
so maybe like you're building a model
and you just want all the features for a
given user um to immediately
kind of pass your model so in practice
right you might think that uh you just
want to have all that stored on the same
table uh as part of what your you know
what i'm turning the online store which
is the database that
you're using to store these features
that you serve to the to the end model
right
and that you know can work in practice
right but in practice you know there's
various columns in here that are being
updated by different
sources so you have some for example in
this use case
user metadata that's not really going to
be changing that often you have some
other things that will change a lot more
frequently maybe like you have like a
user location
a user like you know last item that they
kind of reviewed and that's going to be
coming from very different event sources
and that's all going to be modifying
this kind of view of the table and you
need to keep track of time stamps in all
this because you want to ensure that you
can monitor like freshness of features
and
kind of within this left side view you
don't really know
kind of what timestamps match to which
one so you really need to have time
stamps for each
field right and contrast that to the
right hand side
which is basically the approach that
fees takes right which is you
split it split it up by the actual
source and now you can have
event time stamps that match to a
variety of things like any any feature
that may be updated at the same time
that has one time stamp
and this this lets you also avoid some
sort of read
or write contention as well right like
traditional databases you only really
have
uh row level locking or transactions and
so this makes it a lot easier because
now you know the tables are more likely
to be updated quickly that you can all
that's separated from see the user
metadata or you can have two different
streams that are both simultaneously
updating their own respective tables
right and you won't run into any issues
there
but to me like the most important
benefit of this is it's a little is a
lot simpler to manage right
and this will also match
the data schema that you're going to
have in your
in your data lake for example
so it just makes a lot more sense in my
mind and in practice what i've seen is
that the latency hit is not that bad if
you split it up into tables
but there's a lot of cases where you
know the left hand side could make a lot
of sense too right
um yeah so the second example here is
around how do you encourage future reuse
across models and how do you manage
costs right so
um
and in a lot of cases you the the goal
you know a lot of people come to feature
stores and say well i want to encourage
reuse the features across different
models across different teams
but this introduces unique challenges
right like what happens if you have a
model in production
that rely you know say you have two
models that run on the same features
what if you know some upstream user
that's working on one of these models
says i want to update like an embedding
right
and they just go ahead and kind of
update that
that
will then cause the second model to just
like start having unexpected behaviors
right and so
how do you get around that you need to
think about feature versioning right so
the example i have here
um
i guess actually doesn't
uh crisply
articulate that in particular but um
i guess yeah the embedding example
probably is more instructive
the this example i think is more useful
for thinking about cost management so
one
kind of sample example
of how you might use
this is you're trying to predict like
user buying patterns and you want to
include features of like the last five
items that the users buy right so you
kind of have a transaction id that has a
bunch of features corresponding to that
and you're storing all these features
somewhere within
uh within a feature store right and
as you can imagine well
you not all these transactions really
matter you want to actually expire them
over time right because
presumably a transaction that happened a
year ago is not
not going to be super important
there's a little warning there right
which is that what happens if you have
different models that all rely on this
data so you could have
for example one model that only needs
the last five transactions and another
model that needs to last like 28 days of
transactions right and so you need to
kind of be a little bit careful about
how you manage this
another
challenge that we run into
is with managing types so there's kind
of a correctness angle to this as well
as a performance angle so the
performance angle is
on the fly you're kind of you have to do
some sort of like marshaling of of types
so the user when they expect a response
they have you know one set of type
systems that they want to
collect but the infrastructure person
building that is working with different
type systems so like maybe you're
working with like some models or using
redis as an online source some models
are using dynamo they all have distinct
type systems and so you want to actually
introduce an abstraction a separate type
layer so that the users don't
necessarily need to know what the
underlying implementation details are
right so that results in you having to
on the platform side having type
conversions and that can be very
expensive especially as you scale in the
amount of data you
uh output
got it we'll move more quickly
the tlr of this is that uh you know in
practice what you really need is like a
standard type system that works across
the board and we've started leading more
more into apache arrow as a solution
for this
um and then batch retrieval so i wanted
to kind of quickly dive into some of the
example strategies here
since i think we've already talked about
what the what the problem here is
so
um in this example
right like it really matters what the
boundary that you draw for
this the system is this feature store
system is so if you want to retrieve a
bunch in this example it's uh
say you want to fetch a bunch of
features for a bunch of stores like you
want to match a user to the most likely
store they want to buy from right
if you just tell
if you just say like give me all the
features for a bunch of different
entities well then the system doesn't
really know how those entities are
distributed and so you may actually
start hitting multiple partitions or in
redis clusters you might have to send
separate
network requests to different nodes in
order to get the actual features you
need
but if you can actually encode some of
that right like and more likely you
actually want
near nearby stores to all be collected
at the same time those are that's more
likely right so there's a lot of
benefits to having the system understand
more end-to-end what's happening here
and being able to optimize that on the
storage level
i'm going to
just jump through a little bit more
um yeah this is i think just a pretty
standard pattern where it is uh
beneficial to have different caching
layers so probably the biggest point
here i think is that different stores
have different benefits and to support
different use cases one example here is
that
more traditional databases like dynamo
they're very good for like range range
scans right whereas redis is very it's
just at the end of the day
a really really performance key value
store right that
kind of works i mean technically they're
both key value stores but redis is not
as optimized for your range scans so you
often want to have multiple caching
layers to
um to
to and redis and practices a lot faster
for use cases it supports right so you
can
cache all those hot items and entities
that you want in redis and then kind of
defer fall back to dynamo
if possible
right
um let's see i have eight minutes left
is that right
cool
so i'm just going to zoom past this so
as you can imagine there's a bunch of
different ways that bad data can fall
into this there's
including
like you have faulty transformation
logic you have um streams that are just
giving you bad data there or maybe
they're failing and these they stop
publishing you so you have stale data
right and so within this you know given
that feature source managing the entire
um
life cycle of this data as it becomes a
feature uh more pretty naturally you
would imagine that you need to have some
observable
observability layer here and so
um to not only help you figure out where
data is going bad but also maybe like
concept drifts
you know when you should be retraining
your data retraining your models
and uh
let's see and also kind of how do you
how to deal with bad data on the fly if
your streams are giving you bad data so
some sort of fallback mechanism
is usually very useful one thing that i
wanted to call out so feast today does
have integrations with great
expectations which is a an amazing tool
however kind of this is kind of a
standard like i'd say expectation versus
reality kind of situation which is
you expect data to be all like pretty
easy to figure out that like drift and
anomalies are kind of easy to figure out
in practice you have to you have data
scientists for looking at each metric or
each feature that you're working with
and setting thresholds to make this kind
of system possible right and that that's
a very what we've seen is that that's a
very uh intensive process and so
the first cut of feast is just a simple
integration but an area that i see as
being
relatively
untapped right here is like how do you
abstract a lot of that kind of manual
twiddling that you need to do to make
this system not be super
kind of false positive heavy right
i'm just gonna skip over that that was
an architecture of how feast handles it
um
this uh i'm just gonna skip over this
too but the this the
theme here is basically that
you might you might think that a simple
transformation library might just help
so like at any time you call this one
transformation library a certain time
you call this transformation library
no problem with with transformations and
practice kind of it's a lot more
complicated than that especially when
you think about like how do you get
access to that request data
that you need for all those features
that are really really powerful right
and there's also some uh you know
obvious like differences between how do
you optimize for fast model serving
versus training if you want to achieve
consistency right like you can't just
simply call pandas
in both situations because panda has a
large overhead when you're working with
smaller data sets in serving
um yeah i'm going to skip over this too
um
yeah so so feasts uh just kind of a
quick quick plug here so feast is an
open source feature store that is
actively thinking about a lot of these
issues
and we have a very active community with
over 3000 members and we support a
variety of different stores so like
gcp
aws azure
we have very close partners on the
snowflake side as well and redis and we
do have a large number of on-prem users
um
and kind of you know i've already talked
about how like what the goals of a
feature store are but suffice to say
like a lot of challenges we discussed
today are like very top of mind for me
and how we um you know how we design
this with the goal of simplifying
uh the end user's experience like
the goal is to not for example throw a
lot of infrastructure at you that you
then need to manage because that's only
kind of replacing one problem with a
different problem
right
and yeah i wanted to kind of like show
that
uh this kind of quick web ui on the
right side which is something that we've
been working on recently and a lot a lot
of users when they come to us you know
they talked about how they want to reuse
features
and so a very critical component i think
more critical than the average use case
when you think about
collaboration is a web ui that tells you
helps you manage lineage helps you
manage um
helps you give us an area where you can
see like here's all the data that's
moving around and all the different
observability layers so i would imagine
that this web ui in the future would
also have pretty tight integration with
that data quality monitoring aspect
but let's see uh
and then i think a really key component
here is that there is a plug everything
is very plugable
because every single system has its own
unique use cases and these stance on it
is everything should basically be an
interface so you can kind of use most of
what's already there and then say
abstract away the online store and maybe
like compose different online stores if
you want to do caching or add your own
likes the authentication authentication
layers into
into feast
um
yeah i think this is actually kind of
interesting so
but actually and
talk to me more in office hours if you
want to learn more about how people
deploy feast
um so yeah i think in the batch
recommender system use case really some
of the key value adds here are in that
collaboration and in that like discovery
features uh and understanding that
lineage but really this applies to any
situation where you have models right
that need access to features in
different kinds of environments
and then in online recommender systems
it gets a lot more complicated right you
have a lot of different models you have
like a user tower often that you're
working with you have a re-ranking model
and you're kind of accessing them you
know in one way a training time in a
different very very different way
at serving time right especially since
you try to generate embeddings often on
the fly and so with all that
feast can be a very powerful tool for uh
essentially
getting those like not needing to worry
about how do you move features around um
you can just collect them you know call
the simple api and i'll give you
the the right kind of features at the
right time right um
and then kind of very quickly i wanted
to walk through
uh kind of an example of what a
you know we've talked about like request
data quite a bit um in this presentation
so like what does that actually look
like in feast right so
on the very top on the right hand side
you can see a
declaration of here's all the data you
have access to at request time that's
kind of a feature view that gets
registered
so that people can again data scientists
can understand what additional signals
they have access to
and then on the bottom you can then see
that you know we're doing some simple
like feature crossing that takes some of
this data that you have at request time
and crosses it with
some previous features on the uh that
you are kind of loading into memory from
uh historical data that you kind of
basically you pre compute some some
embeddings or features and you load that
up into memory
but there's a lot of different kinds of
features that uh you know
i'm actively interested in supporting so
talk to me afterwards if you're
interested in learning about learning
out about that a little bit more
um
yeah so kind of some key takeaways is
really that you know the biggest not
real takeaway is that recommended
systems are really complicated right
especially as you move online which is
definitely the trend
and
feature stores i think can help you
enforce best practices in all the
different moving parts of the system
especially with a focus on the data
angle as it relates to features
and uh kind of consistent and performing
on-demand transformations are what we
see as being very very key to kind of
solving a lot of these challenges
in these systems
think that's
it so
i think i'm on time
perfect
so
thank you everyone uh talk to me
afterwards
[Applause]